[MUSIC PLAYING]
SPEAKER 1: Welcome to the
2018 Android Developer Summit.
This is an event for
developers by developers.
SPEAKER 2: With over 2 billion
devices, 3/4 of a trillion apps
downloaded every year,
Android's developer community
is growing hugely.
We saw it more than double
just in the past few years.
SPEAKER 3: So the Android App
Bundle makes it much simpler.
With no additional
developer work needed,
the App Bundle now makes
apps an average of 8% smaller
to download for m+ devices.
SPEAKER 4: So a
few months ago, we
announced Jetpack, the next
generation of Android tools
and APIs to accelerate Android
application development.
Today, out of the top
1,000 applications
in active development
on Play Store,
798 are already using Jetpack.
They are already being used
in over 38,000 applications
worldwide.
SPEAKER 5: The new beta
for Android Studio 3.3
was just released moments ago--
reducing the number of crashes,
hangs, and memory leaks;
fixing user-impacting bugs; and
investing our infrastructure
and tools.
We're bringing the full power
of Android Studio to Chrome OS
early next year.
SPEAKER 6: We simply cannot do
this without you, so thank you.
[MUSIC PLAYING]